Hello, and welcome to the Unreal Engine training course, Control Rig Chaos Physics for Automotive.
This course covers an overview of the Chaos vehicle system and its features.
We'll be going over the steps you need to take to set up a Chaos vehicle in Unreal
Engine version 5.5, some things to consider before you get into the engine, as well
as a brief overview of some of the settings that you'd edit to tweak the feel and handling
of your vehicle.
So by the end of the course, you'll have a fully functional Chaos vehicle that you can
drive around the demo map and be able to take that knowledge and apply it to your own vehicles
in your own projects.
We'll first take a look at some of the Chaos vehicle's features and see what assets
we need to get set up before we can start driving our vehicle around.
Then we'll get into the engine and begin with our wheel blueprints.
These are a super key part of the Chaos vehicle system where you configure a lot
of the information for things like the wheel's attributes, the suspension and the brakes.
And after that, we'll configure the physics asset, the animation blueprint and the vehicle
blueprint.
And we'll connect them all together so that our system has everything it needs to
get moving.
And once that's all ready, we're going to set up the controls for the car using
enhanced input so that we can actually test drive what we've created.
And then once our car's moving, we'll use Control Rig to get the suspension system
animating in real time, reacting to the movement of the wheels.
And lastly, we'll go over some of the settings that affect the vehicle's handling
to give you a kickoff point to start tweaking and customizing your own vehicle settings,
as well as some different setups that will help you get to project finality.